episode 59 by the way you missed it
about 30 seconds ago adam was giving us
10 tips on how to date cougars
and you fully missed that part but who
knows maybe he'll give us a couple tips
this is florida
podcasters today i think it's the first
time we have tom
and uh danielle on the show at the same
time so daniel good to have you in town
good to have you in town it's a big deal
yes what's tomorrow by the way tell us
what's tomorrow's friday
jobs friday that's danielle's like super
bowl non-farm payroll friday yeah
everybody's a big deal
8 30 a.m eastern standard time everybody
has to be quiet
everyone in your house knows do not talk
to danielle on john's friday
so ready to be lied to by the federal
government here come the numbers so from
last time you were on till today what
are the jobs looking like
scarce damn i mean no look
there are so you want to get on this
right away yeah go for it
give it to us let's get into it no
matter what whether
it's across the midwest whether it's
here in florida just driving around
whether it's texas
you can't drive a block without seeing a
help wanted sign that's right there is a
massive under supply of labor in texas
right now
everywhere this is a nationwide
phenomenon because
their federal unemployment benefits that
are being paid to people and
it makes no sense to work if you can get
paid to sit on your ass for a lot more
money
and that's what americans are doing
right now this is so not american what
we're witnessing
so you're saying that but the numbers
show unemployment's you know
doing great economies growing no no no
there are a lot of people who are taking
jobs
but that does not take away from look at
what happened to small businesses during
the coronavirus
you got your big box retailers walmart
was allowed to stay open home depot
lowe's and all the small businesses had
to close and now
bigger companies amazon they can pay a
little bit more per hour to bring these
people off the sidelines
right small businesses can't do that
they don't have the funds and they can't
compete with these large
players so you screwed small businesses
during the coronavirus
you're screwing them now with federal
policy because they
they cannot afford to compete for labor
that wants to sit
on its ass i've seen things like
mcdonald's is paying paying
50 bucks just to come back i'm getting
50 bucks just to get an interview are
you
kidding me no no no no you get i went i
got 50 bucks i got a jump i got a happy
meal
you make a hell of a drive-through
cashier oh yeah i think you'd kill it
what's your joke uh well uh
you wouldn't hit their 59 second time
but you would be like a four-minute
drive-through
it could take a while yeah productivity
would
crash at mcdonald's no question but
because you're sapiosexual people would
want to hear from yourself
i'll explain what that is ding ding ding
ding ding ding where did the day where
are they
what is a sapiosexual tell us that is
when you're attracted to somebody's
brain regardless of how their
outward appearance is doc this is how
you pull all the chicks clearly
this is it this is the
only way i got married
to a teacher by the way make a note we
got to get a shirt saying i'm a
sapiosexual
we got we got to get something right
you're attracted to someone's brain are
you attracted to someone so
daniel thank goodness um you be having
beauty and brains has never been a
problem of yours but
and bullets from a female's perspective
um how important is it looks
versus money wealth brain for a man
because i can tell you for a woman you
know looking at a man i can tell you
what a lot of men in south beach are
looking for and it's not exactly
i mean you you would have their sat
score you would have to put it on a
matrix of sorts you would have to run
like a scenario analysis it depends on
what your objective is
yes really i mean if you actually want
to spend time with somebody
then having no brain doesn't work for
more than oh i don't know
10 minutes okay maybe maybe less can i
tell you what i ask
it all depends it's very that's right it
all depends the key word
it's variable i'll tell you what i ask a
lot of women
in south beach i asked them this
question it's sort of like uh the
running joke that i ask women i brought
this up in the podcast before
i say ladies question for you would you
rather
date like a serious date and or marry a
guy who's like the hottest guy in the
room you know matthew mcconaughey george
clooney type
leonardo dicaprio that guy you know but
you say those names those are
smart guys you got to say somebody who
just got the lord i'm just saying very
good-looking
guy very good-looking guy or broke his
[ __ ] he lives with his parents at home
and
uh lives in the basement see or okay
that doesn't do it for you or wealthy
super intellectual successful
intellectual sapiosexual
complete sloppy dude three hundred
pounds bald gross
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa nothing not hitting on the
ball people i'm just saying he's not
taking care of himself those are your
two options what are we going with
he's successful okay the three pounds
that does not fit inside the scenario
analysis anywhere
you're going with the broke good looking
guy yeah for about 10 minutes
i'm talking about a serious relationship
i would love to hear what you need but
what you're doing you need a third
option
i'm like who are you the big the
dictator in the world you get two
options
party though nobody i got a third one
for you or or
a 40 year old single man handsome
good looking can pull off a mustache a
beard comedian
smart goodwood money saves his money
doesn't drive
you know trying to get adam married
again what like if you have an option
like that yeah that's the direction i
got to go
that guy's on the way right here right
sounds like that sounds great
so how the hell did we go from jobs yeah
to to your idea of who
because i'm looking for unemployment is
that what you're looking for tom how did
you get
we met your wife a couple weeks ago the
biz knock babe the biz doc babe
she doesn't have a name she just goes by
the biz dog babies that's what i call
her how did you pull that
because she's smart attractive loyal
how did you pull that it was the it was
it was the classic golden retriever at
the beach trick what's that
you know where you you throw a tennis
ball over at the pretty girl
sitting there with her friends and your
dog goes over there then you go over i'm
terribly sorry and then
you strike up a conversation so what
happened in real life uh i was at church
believe it or not
and my friend's daughter was talking to
this rather attractive lady
very attractive lady i thought wow she's
cute so i walk over to megan
which is my friend's daughter i said
megan who's your friend
oh this is miss fanbury she's my teacher
and
my first word stir was hello miss fambre
boom
so you got a referral from an
eight-year-old uh yeah who is her
teacher
nice and under the guise of being
concerned that my friend's daughter
as soon as we get off the air i'm going
to go buy you a puppy
and some tennis balls you didn't know
that two cats is what he's got
yeah yeah yeah i'm so sorry
he's got two cats i'm a cat guy no no
you can't you can't say that out loud to
women
i know but they they meet the cats they
fall in love they judge me and then they
come over they see the cats they say
not so bad any good cats okay yeah
back to that i'm not opposed to a dog i
just so my ex-girlfriend liked cats we
got cats
non-farm payroll fridays let's hear the
conclusion to your story you got the
referral
no we just struck up a conversation and
started talking under the guise of me
being very concerned that megan was
speaking to a stranger
hold on i got i got to do a stranger
danger
yeah no i struck up a conversation and i
went from there what are you what are
you looking for what are you looking for
what are you looking for we're not
turning this to a doctor
because we could talk about this for two
hours yeah that's right we went back had
a couple shots of tequila
okay get rid of the cats b get a puppy
okay we've gotta we we
need to write a list you know what i'm
most excited about today because i know
we're gonna get to the top elon musk
guess i know
i'm actually excited that the biz doc
and miss danielle di martin first time
ever i've never met in person right
it's crazy they see each other in
valuetainment economics it's like ships
crossing tonight yeah but they've never
actually got out of board with each
other so i'm excited for this what a
brilliant
smartest people i know the planes do fly
yes and today
your interview with tom just went live
30 minutes ago so it's going to be on
economics go check that out i
interviewed the biz doc a month ago on
jobs friday danielle and i sat down
the interview crushed it she crushes it
like she does everything it was the day
drinking it was the
we this is i think a theme that i'm
doing day drinking now hopefully if we
get to 3 500 viewers
she's not a tequila person she said i'm
not a ticket but but let me tell you the
country is
so 2020 was a huge year for liquor
consumption in america we know that
people were
cooped up at home and drinking a lot but
tequila shot it out of the park
overall year-over-year sales that 10
super premium ultra high end sales up 20
percent you have
tequila's hot hot hot hot hot tub is it
just the ultra premium or is it tequila
overall
well it's um well a lot of intelligent
hot men have decided to attach their
name to tequila brands
the rock who else lebron who else
who is the first the first george
clooney what's his last name clooney
right clooney clooney something eh
cooney what's that what's that new
singer that came out avril lavalle
no you know you know it's really
interesting
[Music]
there's a rule if you don't know how to
say somebody's name
well that's what happened yes yeah pat's
going through the list of like who the
top musicians are okay we got drake
and we got bad bunny we got uh billy
eilish and who's this avril lavon
it's avril lavigne pat okay she had to
throw that g
at the level you know what's really
interesting about them what's good about
liquor live from paris
no no no no that should have been
recorded but because i would have gotten
cracked up this really teaches you
something that you know like from a
marketing standpoint so for people that
are listening to valuetainment they
actually want to get something out of
this today
then let us get back to jobs in the
economy you know
uh liquor has become like fashion browns
and craft beer has been like fashion
brands
if you go back from from 2000
to like 2010 that was like the heyday
here comes the vodka remember all these
vodka brands came out there like this
tito's in texas which is now nationwide
people don't know that's a great
entrepreneur's success story
but they're like fashion brands wrapped
around it there's a mystique there's
something now it also has to be very
very good it can't you know i'm saying
your liquor's got to be
good and now right now we're in like the
golden age of tequila
and it started with george clooney and
everything i think this is very very
interesting
right now the 2020s are are tequila and
tequila
are you a particular person yourself
right now uh i am not really a hard
liquor person as you know i'm a craft
beer person you've known me yes that's
right um
and so i don't i don't have martinis but
i'll have one
once in a while like the biz update and
i go to
ruth chris or something i'll have a
martini because it just seems like white
tablecloth like nice dinner and
everything like that
but not ten but i'll have one but i'm
really
leaning back on i've seen all these
super premiums come out and they're
really really do we know why they're
doing are they doing
great the last 12 months because
celebrities came out with it and people
are clinging to their names are they
doing good
because during the pandemic people just
decided to start drinking
i think casamigos kind of changed the
tequila dynamic i mean for a while it
was like your high end was patron
and once you crossed that berry to
custom he goes all of a sudden it was
like oh
wait exactly and some people like stop
and say wait that's
that's the cool thing adam are you
drinking that coffee and nobody
intentionally or nothing sorry i
apologize
nobody talks about patron these days
have you noticed patron was like a rap
they do but it's not
at the level of what's happened and i
agree yes it's become the mixer right
right it's what you it's like a patron
his beautiful house around right
hillsborough area
highland beach yeah beautiful area
danielle you're a chardonnay girl
myron i am i keep napa in business oh
i do really i was married in rutherford
wow so i'm into carneros specifically
our second girl was conceived on a napa
trip
and we didn't that's my favorite more
information than we could that's great
this was after after she in the uber
ride
after she destroyed the agreed-upon
budget for the trip
in a single one-hour uh
stop at cake bread so it was all the um
tom the sentence that she destroyed i
was ready
i was thinking you're going in a
different direction but it was it
was amazing let's stay appropriate let's
stay reported that cake bread's an
exception
last question before we move on that's a
budgetary not
for christmases where you know for
christmas with uh who's it
uh vince vaughn and uh uh is it reese
witherspoon
and then it goes to his dad's house and
says that's denver that's dallas
he says our parents named us after the
city they conceived this indeed
so you just kind of made me think about
that but there's no correlation there
because there is no such thing as a city
called bailey
or there is berkey though but it wasn't
brooklyn haley was making
maybe you were drinking bailey yeah
anyway i'm lining up with the chardonnay
thing because
i'm married i'm married to a chardonnay
you're not a tequila guy
when you do i wasn't about to kill a guy
i was a little inside
army i was hardcore to kill a guy in the
army every weekend
we'd finish one of those small jose
cuevos on friday and saturday
for about a year and a half straight and
then eventually i can i can't even stand
the smell of tequila
couldn't even stand the smell of tequila
and now you'll drink what
old-fashioned is what i'll do maybe one
maybe one is what i'll do
yeah and then but i used to like blue
moon i still like blue moon a lot tom
and i would have a lot of blue moon
together but
uh yeah i'd probably do old-fashioned
today and that's pretty much it jose
cuervo nobody talks about jose these
days
unless if you're in the military they
still talk about it okay jose
jose it's not going away just so you
know that jose is not going to be going
away anytime soon well drink
but anyways speaking it is like a wild
drink even the 1800s yeah it's like that
was the old
super patron let's stay on the west
coast okay because what's in the water
in seattle already i mean uber
billionaires getting divorced
it's i mean what do you think about that
what do you think cause you know
obviously
a part of it is basil's you know bezos
good school mckinsey but what do you
think about this one so bezos i
understood
right because when they split up he he
was bezos was always known
until he kind of changed his ways as
being the least charitable
multi-billionaire on the planet that he
just wasn't philanthropic at all
and so when they when when he and his
wife split up
she immediately starts to give billions
and billions of dollars away
she marries a teacher she's humble pie
you understand where the tension in that
marriage
that makes sense yeah i don't get this i
don't get i don't i i don't i don't i'm
talking about bill gates they are a and
they're going to continue melinda and
bill gates are going to continue to run
the foundation together have you heard
all the different speculations and
stories on why it is like have you heard
well he had a girlfriend that he's been
going and even the girlfriend he asks
approval to
marry melinda and this girlfriend him
have a place that they go see every year
that's a secret hiding spot on new york
post story and then there's other
stories
so what's in the water in seattle didn't
bezos have somebody on the side
bezos was with that girl that tom zenner
knew what's uh
a latina girl yeah she's a you you would
recognize that
she was married to the sanchez she was
married to the president i think her
last name is sanchez
well because because it was melinda who
filed
for divorce not bill or lauren sanchez
lauren sanchez her name is yes what
would i say lorena that's a she's the
helicopter pilot by the way
orville yeah so let's get into it pat i
feel like uh
stories but you want to talk about gates
let's talk about okay i don't know if
you want to read the list of stories
today or talk about games yeah
no i think we go to the jobs i think we
never finish the jobs because you were
concerned about the definition of
you know sapiosexual but tell us about
what's going on with the job market
so the job market right now is hot
we have an under supply issue in america
that is being largely driven by china
china's got
they're sitting on tons and tons of
steel they're the world's largest steel
producer by a magnitude of
10. it started with the trump
tweet that started the trade war that
really pissed him off
and then comes the coronavirus so we
what started with the supply chain
disruption
has become a disaster for american
manufacturers
they cannot source enough supply
so they're going to higher cost u.s
manufacturers to get
these supplies and they're trying to
ramp up production and they can't
you see ford has shut down production
lines
chrysler has shut down production lines
because they can't get the
semiconductors
and who's flying jets towards taiwan
and who controls the world's
semiconductor supply china
and taiwan taiwan semi so it's
taiwan is huge it's really so yes there
are a l there's a lot of demand right
now in the united states for jobs
there's also eight million people that
we know have not
had their jobs come back but there's
also this massive skills
mismatch right because if you're joe q
who used to work at
at name a retailer jcpenney
macy's that's been closed you've got a
certain skill set you're not going to
pick up and go work in a factory
it's just not going to happen and you're
getting paid a lot to sit at home
between 17 and 20 bucks an hour how
sustainable is this how long can we go
like this
as a capitalist country
or a socialist country if we're if we're
in socialism we can go on like this
forever
we can just pay people to not work just
keep printing just keep printing the
money is that sustainable though to keep
printing money and pay people not to
work
china hopes it is china thinks it is
china hopes
hopes hopes it is in america and yeah
they want to see us bury ourselves
by the way with with socialist policies
i mean the irony
it it's it's inescapable but right now
it looks like we're going to see 998
000 jobs like two months in a row
basically of a million jobs created in
this country
right huge huge huge numbers what kind
of jobs are these are these
good jobs good paying jobs skill sets
needed you know four-year degree jobs or
the entry level right now job openings
for people with
the least amount of education are up 60
percent okay
opening job opening job openings for
people with a college degree
they're up maybe four or five percent so
get out of here
oh yeah okay most of those people didn't
lose their jobs remember they're they're
doing fine they're okay they've kept
their jobs or they got replaced at
another place
right right they worked from home and
now the people who
do have requisite skill sets are like at
google
are saying i'm not coming back in the
office you if you
force me to come back into the office
there's so many jobs out there i'll quit
well daniel question by the way just
just an fyi what she just said right
there is very accurate in
interviews people are saying that right
now yeah well we're interviewing people
you know what i'm talking about they'll
sit there we're interviewing people
engineers they'll say look
yeah i got five offers right now i can
work from home three days and two out of
office are you guys willing to match
that yeah
and they're very confident about asking
that question they're not like sitting
there hey will you please do this now
they're like look
here's what i'm expecting three days
home two days at the office this is a
cushion on the job in the sector
i mean some other some of the jobs you
have no choice but to want to do it
because that's becoming the norm in that
industry but some of the jobs you got to
be at the office
yeah there are some jobs that are coders
engineers you know what we'll work
something out to make that happen but
not every job yeah well
you know what this was my question jamie
diamond just drew this i saw jamie's
story
i'm getting he said i'm canceling every
single zoom meeting i've got let me read
that story i'm gonna read the jamie
diamond store because
you just gave me a couple different
things that you went into one is uh
yesterday i had an hour conversation
with noam chomsky by the way one hour
conversation one gnome chomps
very very distinct yeah world renowned
150 million
150 books he's written 60 years
professor at mit and we went through
capitalism i asked him do you love
america he says what does that even mean
do i love america i love my kids i love
my wife but i don't think one can love
america so are you grateful for what
america did for you and what you know
you were able to do
you know why so what do you look at when
you look at some stuff he says my
philosophy in life is to look at how
things are wrong i look at things that
are wrong not right i said so
he says i'm not the guy that likes to go
to parades i said so you prefer
protesting over parades
so we went back and forth with that it
got pretty heated and uh and then
how do you not love your country oh you
don't need to ask me that question
i don't even begin to understand that
well you have to see the interview to
see how it went because at the end of it
when i asked him about an interview with
him and thomas soul i said look a lot of
your
followers would love to see you in
thomas soul and it's been said that
that's been avoided he says well
i don't really like his writing i read
some of this stuff i'm like you don't
like thomas so you say
i said why don't you do it for the
people why don't you guys do a debate he
says well you already know how busy i am
i said i don't know how busy you are i
said everybody's busy at this point
why don't we do it nobody's too busy i
told them i said if you do it
i will buy a thousand copies of any of
your books and we'll send it to our
listeners twenty-five thousand dollars
what do you want me to do any of your
books i'll buy a thousand copies of it
well you saw how hard it was for us to
get you i said we just asked you a
couple months ago so no you've been
trying for years i said i don't know if
we've tried four years so
anyways long story short it's a very
interesting interview coming up but he
was talking about
the concepts of socialism and you know
the businesses
these people that are tyrannical leaders
like the gates and all these other guys
it's the people that build the companies
anyways
here's where i'm going with it where you
know tom's famous line yesterday pat
is this i got to hear three stories
before your point
so i've been following forbes ever since
a chinese china investment company
bought forbes
okay they own 95 of forbes a hong
kong-based investment company bot forbes
forbes has historically been a what a
pro-capitalism
freedom pro america magazine i don't
know if you've been following their
poster like six years cool
i don't read the fortune magazine but i
will go forbes we subscribe to forbes we
don't subscribe to fortune right steve
forbes now when you look at
it now when you look at it yesterday tom
made such an interesting comment he says
i said why the hell is forbes
supporting some of these comments that
hey socialistic ideas and
edifying and building up certain
characters they would have never built
up six years ago seven years ago right
then you look at it ninety five percent
they own five percent they own he says
china would like
americans to believe socialism is good
while they go in a completely different
direction
they don't care whether it's good or not
they just care that it divides america
i don't know if there's truth behind it
or not all i'm saying is the fact that i
think it's more fundamental
they are u.s politicians are playing the
short game china's playing a lot 100
and china's like we're going to use
capitalism quietly
in a communist regime we're going to
employ capitalism
to overtake the united states and we're
going to encourage socialism in the
united states so that we can weaken it
so it's an
taiwan is not a 70 70
70-year uh grudge match on the make good
that they think it's their
territory you know what taiwan is
semiconductors it's an enhanced market
share play on semiconductors
because if they assimilate that they get
more market share on semi they get more
market share on
textile manufacturing there is a ton of
stuff that you look there
they want to assimilate this yeah it's
political and yeah they got the planes
flying overhead and this kind of
militaristic and stuff
but really what this is this is market
share of western manufacturing
and and the chinese
state has been pouring money into
into domestic semiconductor
manufacturers in
on on the mainland and they fully intend
to have between taiwan and china they
fully intend to control the world's
semiconductor supply while biden's like
well we'll we'll consider 50 billion
dollars and i'm like yeah good luck with
that
yeah i mean it's it's good luck with
that how what do they control right now
the production of any pharmaceutical
industry is coming out of china it's a
good you hear
80 some say 60 percent that's a big
number semi-con
what else are they controlling
telecommunications
huawei's huawei's got a third of the
world's
telecommunication equipment is one con
one company huawei
and they they're at the forefront of
robotics because they have to be because
their one child policy
is backfiring so their population's
beginning to shrink
so but they've known this they've known
this for a long time they they see the
data
so they're at the top of robotics they
get the mic a little closer audience is
saying they can't hear
good so they're at the top of the
automation chain because they know they
have to replace
their own people so and that puts them
at the front of
artificial intelligence and think of the
control that they can have
think of the control that they can have
over the global economy
germany has tighter economic ties with
china than germany has with the united
states
because they export so much to china and
when you think about world war ii i know
it's a long time ago
but the world is split
along lines and they're always economic
lines
and are you allied with china who
butters your bread
or the united states because they've
always been your ally your friend
traditionally in a post-world war ii
regime
so but again money talks
and your third story
no the worlds are worse i'm limited to
two today i'm working on myself
i believe the world is at war we just
don't see it that way and right now we
have producer
supplier wars and the only difference is
we don't have a bunch of poor serfs with
pitchforks
being led by the knights as one king
fights another king
but we are in the middle of producer
supplier wars on a global basis and we
just don't understand or see it that way
i'm going to throw a statistic out there
that's going to give you an idea of how
much america has
changed okay when the boys went off
to fight world war ii all right they
were leaving
a country that had been decimated by the
great depression
they'd seen they grew up in the roaring
20s
and the average age of a gi in world war
ii was their early 20s so
they they they enjoy the early the the
roaring 1920s
heyday when they were children and then
through their teenage years when they're
so
impressionable they're in the great
depression they come back
and world war one veterans they gave a
train ticket and 50 bucks
and there was awful unemployment among
world war one veterans
shame on the country staying on the
country the politicians when they were
coming back said we're not going to do
that to our veterans we're going to take
care of our veterans
they came back part of the gi bill we
had the biggest
college acceptance we had the best
best best birth rate in the world the
baby boomers
home ownership went through the housing
was massive but this was all va
and this was this was paying to go to
college and this was this is assistance
getting into homes
there was a huge aspect of the gi bill
that was for unemployment
only 20 percent of those funds were
tapped the boys came back and they
refused to take the government's money
because they loved their country
they want it to work and they wanted to
work for it and they wanted to get into
if they were going to get help they were
going to get help getting educated not
sitting on their ass and look at where
we are today by comparison
it's crazy you know what's crazy she's
saying that let me tell you i had a 26
000 auto gi bill never use it i got a
couple thousand dollars i stopped so
we had friends that they you just had to
take like six courses or two courses
whatever it was and they would send you
to 1200 bucks every month you
whatever the course was it was you know
you could so guys weren't working and
they were just taking the gi bill that
would come to you
and then there were certain people that
are like nah i'm good man i'm gonna go
out there and you know do something else
but
i can see that pride level of you know
being high then but today
man it's it's you know what i said to
the guy here's what i said to know him
yesterday i'm just
all night i've been thinking about this
conversation it's so i said i said no
let me ask you a question
i said i read your books i watch your
documentary he has a new documentary
that came out requilm of the american
dream
i may not even be pronouncing that ward
right right of
the american dream and so i said if i
had
a hundred students that knew nothing
about america
they don't have an opinion about america
like imagine if you took me at 18 i
don't really have an opinion about
america i wasn't a guy that paid
attention in history class
1.8 gpa guy i'm not like out all of a
sudden 21 i started reading books right
i said if i gave you 100 students that
went into your class
and you taught them by the time the
semester's over with they're going to
hate america
they're going to hate america you asked
them that questions i said because i
said
everything you're talking about it's
like you know going
and you know what was the scariest part
here's the scariest part
60 years he's been a professor at mit
60 so imagine 60 years
of saying his philosophies and so my
brain went to my son
my oldest son wants to be a scientist so
guess what i'm selling them on
mit mit so i'm saying you're going to go
and be taught by
what the hell is a person who's going to
kill you i'm not saying that's everybody
i'm not saying that's everybody but by
the way i mean a
i took noam chonsky to task in my book
fed up
b i at the root of the rot
at the federal reserve and this idea
that we can print all the money is what
we call the mit mafia
we call it the mit mafia because of how
economics
is taught how people are brainwashed at
that institution that is considered to
be
one of the the best economic
institutions in the country
the other one did you mention thomas
soule did you mention stanford
of course the opposite end of the of the
intellectual responsibility
and we need a lot more of them at the
fed then we need
the mit mafia well you've seen the
painting i have in my office the the one
with milton friedman in there you'd be
amazed how many people come and say
why would you put that guy on there all
he cared about was profits
all he cared about is profits right you
know the whole thing but milton friedman
the black guy he gets is the fact that
all he cared about was prophets but
we need more milton friedman if anybody
you don't like
ricky you've seen ricky's passion of
course ricky prior to working with us
never followed capitalism he wasn't like
a capitalism guy ricky was a guy that
grew up in a mexican
you know what do you want to call it
mutual cartel carter you know i don't
want to say but you know he's been into
whatever levels of his family very
powerful family he's been around that
for a while right he openly talks about
it himself you know what's the first
video i told him to watch
i said if you really want to but but i
said i'm gonna give you a video to watch
but be very careful he says what's that
i said if you watch one you're gonna go
down a rabbit hole you're gonna watch a
hundred of his videos
milton friedman milton friedman phil
donahue when they talked about
greed and he told phil donahue he says
what do you say about all these rich
people that are so greedy and all they
care about is money and then milton
friedman said
you know it's always the other guy
that's greedy you're not the one that's
greedy it's always the other guy right
always the other guy that's greedy we
forget that we're greedy you're telling
me you're not greedy phil
people here are not greedy who's the
only one that's greedy the government
that's greedy nader's not greedy i'm
sorry but you're being a little too
naive that whole part when he had the
exchange
if a person wants to learn about
economics go down the rabbit hole of
milton friedman
look what will happen to your brain a
month later
then go listen to the opposing argument
and try to put those two together and
see what happens
yeah i mean to me all i thought about is
if kids are going to school and that's
going to be the influence
of like if a regular kid was sitting
there saying why would you love america
you're supposed to love your family
why would you love america why would you
love this why would you love them like
oh my gosh so
anyways i think there is a major shift
on the way kids are thinking and i hope
it doesn't go in the direction because
yesterday i was in our armenian podcast
this girl named sona was interviewing me
very professional she's been in a media
site
in la for a while you know done some
interviews larry king all that stuff
very attractive and very well spoken but
specifically on the armenian side
and we were talking about media she's
asking me all these different questions
about media
and uh what about armenians this what
about armenians that and i said look
you have to realize what's going on
right now with uh education she says
armenia you know do you have any
opinions of what happened i said armenia
got bought by china china put 14 billion
into armenia i said you realize once you
do that
you're owned by china so china's going
around slo you know yesterday a
couple people on chinese uh uh what do
you call it government
went out and tweeted you read the story
that they went out their own not tweet
about india making fun of india look at
india they're doing 400 000 cases
the government officials are making fun
of india why india's going because
india doesn't want to go in bed with
china so they're taking shots at them
india's telling china we don't want you
and look what china's doing you don't
want
us no problem they have a vaccine
shortage no problem
look at the way they're controlling the
vaccine shortage
where is it coming from this is a very
interesting game plan these guys have
put together for the last 30 40 years
and fyi one guy said something to me
says this is nothing new
this has been going on for a long time
this is chinese's you forget this is not
a 200 year old
nation this is not this is thousands
they're experts in the war what are you
talking about
clinic on war if you study that part of
the world
india and australia and new zealand are
kind of isolated
economically and china is everywhere
else
you think eventually somebody's going to
get elected in india and they're going
to
cave and cave in you know do business
with china and take money from them
it depends on where we are i hope that
never happens because i think
i think if there's one country that we
that
is the one china doesn't want to see the
excel cxl
i think it's india it's because of the
demographics i think it's in
one point three one point what is the
number one point two one is it one point
the only country that has a larger
population than china yeah so that's of
course that
yeah see that that's the state china and
india they have that's like half the
population in the world if they
figure out how to at this point what is
india figured out they got the best
engineers
they produce some of the best engineers
they do what they don't have is
infrastructure they don't have
infrastructure
yeah i agree and but that's i mean hello
where the united states of america i
mean
we can't build roads here but we can
help them build roads
don't don't don't hit the infrastructure
button while we're on the topic of china
and everything that danielle talked
about
you actually your story with world war
one and the world war ii the vets come
in
it's it's actually the the timeline of
that it's actually amazing because
it kind of culminated in the late 50s
early 60s and that's probably why jfk
said
don't ask what your country can do for
you ask what you can do for your country
so it's interesting that that culminated
in that
and that was when we had the space race
i mean i just i got goosebumps when
you said science and mit if we keep
this space race going then we'll
figure out income inequality if we can
get rid of the teachers unions that have
just about
i mean if anybody doesn't understand
that the t post coronavirus
that the teachers unions do not have the
children's
best interests at heart thank you unpack
that
look i live in texas my kids have been
in
the classroom every single day social
distancing
masks be careful every single day of the
school year
my kids there are blueprints all across
america for how to do this all you need
is one school to get it right and then
replicate that's all you need and yet
you've got
teachers unions in chicago los angeles
new york
holding out holding mothers and
mr mom's absolutely i have to be careful
about that i get slaughtered by the dads
who are like i'm i'm the dad at home i'm
like
okay but keeping half of the income
out of the household because one parent
has to be there to supervise
virtual learning and it is i mean if we
cannot figure out
how to put and this is something that
people can do by the way there is this
thing called the constitution
we don't have to wait for the democrats
and the republicans to
duke it out we can get rid of collective
bargaining
via the constitution we forget that we
have that we can get rid of term limits
by the constitution how you have to dust
off the politicians in congress right
now they've been there for so long
but but there are things that can be
done in this country with the
constitution
by the people for the people that don't
revolve around
politics that's broken but teachers
unions have to go
when you think of the space race in the
50s and the best era in this country
we were sending somebody to the moon and
kids were waking up and saying i want to
be an astronaut and their parents like
you want to be an astronaut you better
study your math you better
study your science but they wanted that
they had the desire
so i'm watching the modern day space
race today and i'm like go for it
you can't tell children to get excited
about math and science
but you can show them and they can want
to succeed
and if we start home growing our brain
power
as opposed to importing it into our
graduate degrees graduate programs and
then
re-exporting it to india and china think
of what we could do as a country but you
got to get rid of the teachers unions
first
daniel with the space race though i feel
like in the 50s and the 60s it was such
a new thing are you kidding me we're
going to space
like what like mind blown now it's like
elon musk did another rocket today nasa
did another thing
it's so we take it for granted like i
don't feel like it's that
it has the allure that it had such a new
thing
oh i don't know what's the number how
many people i've been to
569. 569 humans have been to space
569 out of how many people like seven
billion no doubt that it's amazing
today but it's it's not what it was ten
billion at least nineteen years
disagree buddy you think you think it
still has this just hear the statistics
five sixty nine out of eight
seven eight billion people have been are
you like that's a very big deal
what does that mean though because of
the track adam what were we just talking
about
controlling semiconductors controlling
science
right what if there's rare earths up
there what if we can mine some of that
stuff look i'm all about space i'm just
saying i think a lot of people
aren't look how many before prior to
1960 how many people had been to space
zero now a lot of people have been in
space
500 something people i just look i'm not
downplaying the importance of going to
shape
i'm all about america you have a man
crush on musk
i have a man i have a lifestyle the
lifestyle i'm just saying
i don't think that's right now it's now
you got you got musk
and bezos having a war and then when
that's good
okay that's great i think that's great
and then it's so trivialized that
musk will tweet at bezos like oh look
who can't get it up wink wink like
it's it's because he's a comedian no
yeah we'll be on snl this time
i disagree with this i disagree with
this and i'll point to two things and
you can go look at the ratings on tv and
with the interest of the
of american people around the world
disclaimer father's a rocket scientist
you just offended him so i just want to
know
back up that's correct my my my mom's
dad my grandfather was a machinist
making machine parts southern california
aerospace industry he was just a
machinist blue collar
but he was making parts for his
important stuff my dad yes was a rocket
scientist
i'm sorry for offending your dad the
rockets no no it's okay it's okay screw
you
he shows with a smile so there's two
things that you saw
one was and it goes back about this it's
like six years ago
remember when the red bull stunt guy
felix went up to the
the edge of atmosphere and jump that was
the highest skydive all the time did you
see how many people were watching that
and how interested they were
and all those things was going on there
was nothing going on but him talking to
the guy going all the way up up and then
he did it
the second thing is when elon musk just
what was it
four months ago brought the two first
two astronauts back astronaut dave and
astronaut bob whatever the guys
remember those astro dave astro bob and
he brought him back and they landed and
they showed up
picking the ship picking up the capsule
america was enthralled wow somebody
other than nasa pulled this off
go look at the ratings on that i i don't
think you're correct i think there's a
lot of
interest in what's going on there and
that people are pretty amazed that the
stuff is happening whether it's nassar
yeah i mean
what percentage of the country was
interested in that story
give me a number what percentage of the
country was interested in that story
i don't know but the ratings were huge
okay but just give me a percentage
actually this is a very qualified moment
to say what the hell is your point
where are you going with this 100 of the
country was interested in 1960. maybe
it's 20 percent now
oh my god on all the trading floors on
wall street when they when they landed
the probe on mars
cnbc bloomberg everything turned off we
watched we watched that landing i mean
i just got space add this to your list
with women why haven't you been to the
moon since 1986. so tell us when you
were in high school in 1960s
what was it like when uh i gotta tell
you he's not gonna experience that
thing i think you just want to be an
astronaut in the ocean that's i think
what you're trying to do i'm trying to
get out there oh i get to swim at some
point very cool
i just i think it was yeah like a bigger
deal in the 60s than it is today what i
think she was
the point she was trying to make is to
get kids to dream
again yes let's go do the impossible
whatever the hell is the i talked to a
doctor is it michi
akaku i may not be saying the name right
you know who he is he's a theoretical
physicist he's like one of those
what's the french pronunciation of his
name listen i'm gonna butcher it if it's
english or whatever
i actually think i got that one right
the other one i i totally butchered
so the asian guy yeah the white hair top
15 favorite interviews of all time yeah
favorite enemies of all time top 15. so
stop stop so so i'm talking to him and i
said so tell me uh
uh uh is there civilization out there at
this point of the game we know there's
civilization out there i said
uh you said once you know let's stop
trying to find out about them because if
we do find out about them what if they
are
ten times more powerful than us right
and i said okay i said so here's a
question for you says
i said do you think there's a twin of
america
in you know i'm not america of the uh
the earth out there as
in space another earth out there he says
i'm willing to bet there
is and what's scary is they may be
millions of years ahead of us you know
what i said i said i don't think that's
possible he says
he says why do you think that is i says
you think
you really think this thing's going to
continue i said you don't think there's
an
end time to this he says what do you
mean i said you don't think you
think like we're going gonna go the way
we're going right now and not
one insecure crazy offended i said what
happened in germany do you remember the
guy with the weird-looking mustache
do you know half the story why he did
what he did is because he was offended
because somebody offended him so he kept
that grudge for a long time
what are you gonna do if another kid
comes and gets offended
and he keeps it for years and all of a
sudden his vision is to destroy
everything you think
he says well that's level one you're
thinking about this i think internet's
gonna do this and
then we talked about whether we can uh
time travel he says that's a possibility
he says this is how you do time
but you know how it sounds crazy think
about it if you sit there and say you
know what i want to go to 1985 okay and
then he explained how
how to go back in time it's just because
if you go back in time and you save one
of your parents from dying or something
now you're messing up with the future
and all this stuff
says then you're going to go into three
dimensions listen i i honestly i felt
like i was on lst and i was on no drugs
at that time
you've not seen ant-man yes of course i
have i have but the whole thing is
look it was like it was like how do i
describe this to you it was
uh uh it was uh what was the word that
we started off with the the
the section of sexual it was honesty
porn for
sapiosexual community that's what it was
okay that's a good way of putting it
right that's what it was
because you just listened to this guy
like oh my gosh
now can we time travel i don't know the
fact that somebody thinks we can't
that's
exciting to want to go out there and do
the impossible so adam
to the community of people that party
with you in miami that could care less
about what we can invent
we respect them a lot we salute them
tremendously
but to the other community that wants to
find out what the hell is in space
i applaud them to go find out i'm
actually very curious myself
i agree with you actually yesterday
bezos since he can't get it up they
announced for 200 000
they will take you to space and allow
you to have a view
of what earth looks like from space we
ought to finance you going and seeing
what it looks like from space
i think the four of us should go are you
down for it i'm down for it are you
kidding me
game game if we if we finance it you're
willing to go
beyond yes so let me get this straight
you're not willing to go do street guys
you know street on the what is the the
the the go
colombia but you wanted to go to space
yeah you feel safer in space than
colombia
uh these days maybe yeah all right
i i have to applaud then i got a lot of
respect for you with that i'm all about
space i just don't think a lot of
americans care as much as they did in
the night well what she's saying is
agree with danielle i just think folks
do you agree with adam or do you
agree with danielle if you agree with
danielle put thumbs up if you agree with
adam put thumbs down we're curious
because i'm on team ddb you are you are
anti-space learning about it and we
understand that there's a community for
it
by the way somebody here said the most
you know they said no wonder he's soyboy
the two cats validates it you're getting
a lot of good
people are sending money today and
giving you a lot of love
right i'm good with it okay so wait i
can't hear you wait
we're keeping a list right yes get rid
of the cats
get a puppy it's not gonna happen and
avoid talking about space so
just i'm talking about your pickup
strategy here catastrophe i've
by the end of the show we're going to
have it down and we're going to have the
girl's name from miami because we're
going to narrow it down
to space anthony morrow said send adam
to space i'm going
there you go okay
so it's it's taken us 51 minutes to get
into topics
but this has been great too so i have an
idea i have an idea about what happened
very much i got an idea about bill and
melinda gates speculation
i don't know how you're going to do the
short clips today because it's going to
be like all over the place
but i got an idea about billing they all
need ritalin now
speculation speculation speculation
about bill and melinda gates
i think when the pandemic happened
where people were forced to be around
each other some people realized
i really don't enjoy your company that
much
okay and it's unfortunate because at
least
when you only see somebody at night or
whatever
it's an hour you can tolerate the person
but if you're in pandemic you're in
shutdown mode for six months and you're
bill gates who at the time even though
you're not a doctor you're one of the
voices second to anthony fauci that what
the world should do
and your wife melinda is next to you
who's also got a pretty big ego just as
much as you and you guys are stuck in a
50 million dollar house for freaking six
months
i wonder what those fights would be like
you know i wonder what those fights were
looking like i wonder how annoying they
were to each other and eventually
they're like dude i just
i'm good not being around you anymore
well think about how high her profile is
today compared to what it was say five
years ago i mean
she's done so many interviews she's
become
such an advocate for women and
so but she's not even comparable to
mckinsey right as far as the voice goes
as far as
they're in different leagues and that's
why i mean i i think that
that that she would have never as an
influence
not even close no no no
the lawyers crafted the tweet that they
both wrote melinda i promise you made
sure that
they're going to continue co-running the
the foundation
and they're going to because she's not
giving up her leadership position she's
got she's got a taste for power and
she's not giving it up
she's extremely ambitious from ursuline
to remember
she's using bezos's attorneys she's
using
trump's former attorneys so she is in it
to win it and she's not going to give
give up the power you think she called
trump and said i need a referral
i'm thinking no can i get a referral
donald
we're focusing a lot on her where do you
think those minds she's impressive hang
on a second
melinda gates is very impressive and i
think she honestly believes in the
things she's doing i saw
she was running a massive division of
microsoft yeah and also i saw her
talking about uh
the malaria eradication project was one
of the first of the
gates foundation there's no question
she's a true believer and she was a true
believer i saw her interviewed she was
interviewed by
kara swisher and i was really impressed
i said wow there there's passion
there's how there's when there's who
else i need i was like wow this is like
listening to the business plan for
malaria eradication i was really
impressed it wasn't just
it wasn't just the celebrity that
question for you picks her favorite
that shaves the animals she is shut up
brilliant question for you tom not that
either is going to do it
but which of the two would you think
deep down inside
has more aspiration of wanting to become
the president united states melinda or
bill gates
i have my own opinion what do you think
well if you narrow it down to that
question i think it's melinda i agree
with you
i agree with you i think she's more
aspirational and more ambitious to want
to do something like that and he was
never a power executive he was always a
thinker
and he understood the power that's a
meltdown so he's had some great epic
meltdowns
but he also understands the power of
platform yeah and so when he and jobs
were together
he understood platform he understood
monopolistic power he understood exactly
what he was doing with the
what became the wintel standard whereas
jobs was about design
about innovation about being very
different about being on the edge and
not being
we need to this is the matrix not being
the right there's a there's a
wide age gap between those two as well i
mean bill gates is 65 he's in a
different place in his life he hangs out
with
he you know he and warren buffett are
buddies i mean it's how old is she
playing gin rummy playing generator guy
pull her up i
i she's probably in her mid-50s probably
a 10-year age i think she's 56
okay so there's a nine-year age gap
all right that's not that big of a deal
did we kai check it
yeah okay okay we're showing melinda a
lot of love respect i get it but where's
bill at right now
give me a word biz doc where's bill's
mindset at
i think it's totally fine yeah i think
bill is totally fine
how can you not be at peace with 75
billion
but i but i tell you 100 billion i tell
you it's not even a money part it's
there's also an
element of imagine their debates
[Music]
imagine bill's identity i was like dude
i've been the richest man in the world
for freaking 30 years
until these guys showed up you realize
who i am like everybody's been talking
about me for a while
you and i were you weren't there day one
you ran a division great we met we
hooked up
all all good respect you were somebody
that did a great job with the company
but
i'm bill gates you know i am bill gates
i've done a lot
of the foundation is named after me
let's not forget it it's gay
i know it's but it's but it's gates is
the last time
oh geez so to him his identity
you don't think there is like a bunch of
girls out there who are like scientist
type of girls that are
you know into soci sexual homosexuals
who are like
oh my god gosh get me that's sapiosexual
i want them right now yeah i mean
there's a big
there's a tender site for sapiosexuals
what's it called i don't even know but
it's a good idea what are the chances he
just rolls up with like this hot
model scientist you know what that's a
good one is he goes down that very low
the un underserved
wow think about it somebody right now
listening to this run with it and let us
know about it five years from now when
you go ipo four billion nerd match
can you imagine that if there's a dating
site specifically for
well look minimum requirement to be on
this dating side you have to have a 4.5
gpa like imagine it's like one of those
elite brilliant
genius rocket scientist type of a
community if they've got one for farmers
they can have one for sapiosexuals
wasn't there one that was a six-figure
club
ladder where you would travel and meet
each other at airports
what was it called ladder it was a
dating site specifically for
those six-figure and up executives that
was specifically their market target
market that's one way to filter i think
but by the way i tell you what i like
about that it was the whole idea was
you're so busy you don't have time to
date which
a lot of people nowadays you're an
executive you're running a gun and
traveling you don't have time to date
here's a website find a way to you know
connect and have a cup of coffee
together and maybe you know i mean
look at one of the most popular shows
that's been on tv in in recent history
big bang theory i mean
that went for season after season after
season
sapiosexuals are a thing i i think
that's a word we're going to use
often it's here i think it's going to
stay like so boy stuck
it's tough i don't think it's at that
level though it's not it's not that but
we'll get we'll
we'll do our best to see what we can
okay let's go into uh
shoot we we talked briefly about what uh
our buddy jamie dimon says
let's talk about that go to page five
since we've already covered let's just
get that knocked out of the way
jamie dimon okay
jamie dimon jamie dimon fed up with zoom
calls and remote work says commuting to
office will make a comeback cnbc story
he is no fan of the new remote work
structure that has taken hold during the
coronavirus pandemic
the jb morgan chase chairman and ceo has
already told his employees they should
begin
getting used to returning this month
with the goal of having 50 of workers
rotating through uh offices by july
while he's fine with greater flexibility
a lot by employees working from home
part time he said that's no substitute
for being at the office
i'm about to cancel all zoom meetings jp
i'm done with it but look at the bottom
line diamond also said clients told them
in cases where jp morgan lost
businesses to rivals it was because
bankers from other
guys visited and ours didn't well that's
a lesson
that's the line in the sand and and the
thing is investment banking
is about building relationships and
i mean they've discovered on wall street
that traders can trade from
home they get that even though there is
a camaraderie on a trading floor
that that you know traders feed off of
one another it's an
ego maniacal environment a trading floor
but investment bankers build
relationships
and you know they're they're
golfing they're on the corporate jet
they're whining and dining i mean
mergers and acquisitions have just had
the two biggest months in the history of
the united states in
march and april every merger every
acquisition there's an investment banker
collecting fees behind that deal
ipos are hot right now there's an
investment banker behind that deal
and he's got the people out wherever it
is in the country that you can go out
and
since corona whatever they're going out
to dinner in dallas but they're
physically with
the client is what diamond's saying and
he's saying i'm not going to lose market
share i'm not giving up business
you know what i like about him i don't
even know which side is he's politically
i don't know which side he's politically
center left he sees center left
okay yeah but he he doesn't give a crap
about telling you how he feels about
anything and it's not like he's a
loyalist to his political party or what
everybody on his side is saying he'll
come out and say
this is [ __ ] this is not working out
we got to do something all this
progressive [ __ ] has got to be
pissing him off because before the
election he said oh
i'll hang my hat on biden but you better
stay in the middle
you better not swing too far left okay
so question for you question
this has got to be making it mad what
what's happening in the economy all this
because i'm going to look up the federal
reserve
it's it's inflating a bubble that's
going to come back to haunt wall street
and jamie dimon cannot like it
do you think he's called biden do you
think they've had a conversation about
the tax plan
give me a break he's the most he's the
most powerful banker in the world
fair okay so biden in his camp talking
about the fact that
he always says i haven't spoken to that
person i mean
ask again but biden said to putin in his
face
that you know i know you're playing all
this other stuff but he doesn't talk to
jamie dimon that's
definitely when he needs to use it that
he talks to the people he says it when
he doesn't use it when he hasn't talked
to people he doesn't use it
but going to jail if he was talking to
companies in america right now he would
know that his policies
are hurting companies he would know that
he would know that his policies are are
causing
companies labor costs to increase at the
same time that input costs and shipping
and freight
are going through the roof you're
squeezing the hell out of these margins
with these companies
your story line doesn't match with what
the media storyline is because the media
storyline biden's first 100 days for
stock market best since fdr
but you know that's a that's a story
like hey he's doing such a great job the
first hundred days
34 percent of personal income was
government
transfers we've never seen anything like
the amount of
money sure but how these stories have
been into the economy how the stories
being pitched by mars we're glorifying
we're glorifying socialism yes we are is
that who we are as a country
well then just bring gnome on just we'll
have gnome on next time
run it instead of yeah but let me go
back to the question here's a question
for both of you guys
i want to go with you and then tom i
want you to comment on this as well so
this is my question i had dinner with a
guy two nights ago who's one of the big
estate planners here
solid guy beast of a guy legit guy
and we're sitting out we're talking i
said
do you think biden's tax plan is gonna
happen he says that's the number one
question all my clients are calling me
for
i said do you think it'll retroactively
go back to 11 20 21
because that's what they're pitching he
says let me put it to you this way
90 chance it's not going to happen i
said tell me why he says you have no
idea what kind of people are calling
them because if they do this
midterms will be a nightmare so what do
you think do you think
it will happen retroactive or do you
think it's going to be a 1-1 2022-date
it's you know manchin's already come out
and said he would
maybe raise the corporate tax rates 25
maybe but mansion's your line in the
sand
by the way if you don't get mansion on
board he's your guy
you i mean that that and look
the house of representatives has a lead
of
six six i mean the midterms could be
texas picked up two a slaughter picked
up one california lost one new york lost
one yeah
so but but that's i mean when when you
think about how the lines are being
drawn
and how narrow the margin is in the
house and obviously the senate
split down the middle with joe manchin
joe manchin is more powerful than
paula harris i agree period so
uh how the media is the vice
president and and by the way when the
when the stock market was rising would
have
had nothing to do with trump and it has
nothing it has everything to do with
biden
and it had nothing to do with trump
because when when trump was around for
the majority of the time pre-coronavirus
the fed was basically printing money in
the background right
and then the cares act comes along and
then you zero percent interest
zero percent interest rates when you
look at the
amount of fiscal and monetary
money that's been pumped into this
country it is
upwards of 57 percent i'm telling you
china's
licking their chops they're so excited
to see us going down
to use your term this rabbit hole the
chomsky rabbit hole
thoughts tom well there's about five
things in there and the first thing i
was going to say about jimmy diamond
is you know i become a student of like
the banking leads and kind of understand
you know the story behind the story and
what he brought up here
you know hey i had a market share
problem during coven also people don't
know that on um
on march 5th of last year jamie dimon
was basically dead
he was in he was in his office and he
heard what he thought was a
pop like a crack of a knuckle he calls
his doctor and he said he was
light-headed and things going on
his doctor said i think you may have had
an aortic tear
he did an aorta terror he said okay well
call 9-1-1
jamie you don't have time tell your
assistant to
walk you through the elevator until you
pass out and get you in a cab
and get here and he got in a cab with an
assistant
yep zipping across new york and they got
him in
and they he was hope you ready for this
his doctor said that he was hello jamie
diamond age the doctor said he was open
there was his chest was open
like 42 minutes from the phone call he
made but he said he was as good as dead
and she was a cancer survivor and and
then last year he had two knee
replacements so
jamie so and by the way his first day
back and he was doing the kneeling thing
he was kneeling in front of a chase bank
ball
and it's and all the memes were ah jamie
dimon kneeling in front of his favorite
house of worship
but it was it was a bank vault but
diamond has come back i think to a human
side of business so i think there's more
going on with jamie here
it's market share but i think there's a
human side of it
um with with diamond and also the fact i
think goldman kicked his butt last year
i think during
2020 goldman freaking kicked his butt i
mean we all know that they did
two billion dollars in bonds with the
auto industry which was supposedly ford
they didn't say who
they said our guys never left their
homes in north jersey the
the auto guys never left dearborn oh
dearborn i guess that's ford
and you know they did two billion
dollars with the bonds relationship
wins this is the factor this wins touch
and
so and this is where did you guys want
to work and they said we all don't want
to work in west palm beach and goldman
moved that bond group supposedly to west
palm beach florida
where good job two billion dollars where
do you want back how about west palm
those
income taxes great you can go there the
second thing
that that you were talking about in all
this pump and stuff going in here
you also have to remember what um what
did the youth of america
you know the uh educated youth right you
had college students
early 20-21 more of them took their
stimulus check
and opened up a robin hood account and
so you've had
stimulus money pumping into the market
that's called
demand which drives market prices
of the fanga stocks and anything else
that they want to invest in
so i think you also have to understand
is that the stimulus money
for a huge number of people that got
that stimulus money went right into the
market and it also reduced consumer debt
and so that's artificial
yeah i mean if you look at and i'm going
to make a little point about
jamie dimon one last point about jamie
dimon
i'm getting in the weeds here but it's
kind of critical jamie dimon has the
biggest balance sheet
in america and when there were issues
in overnight lending in late
2019 jamie dimon threw his weight around
and made the made life at the fed
difficult
difficult and what company was bailed
out first
with the fed's bailout on march the 23rd
which company was grandfathered in that
had been downgraded to junk in dearborn
michigan
uh let me guess ford yeah first on race
day
karma's a funny thing but jamie dimon
showed jay powell
that he was more powerful than he was
seriously you know what's really funny
about this is he like a modern-day
sandy wild is he like a modern-day sandy
wild type of person
sandy weil said the worst the the one
regret of his entire career
was not letting diamond succeed because
city would be in the place that jacob he
said oh yeah that's that's that's a
matter of public record
wow by the way props to sandy before
saying that
of course props for sandy for saying
that you know what the power
if you ever lose humility you're you can
kiss yourself you know in that world
it's a lot it's a lot of not being able
to say what the truth is because you got
to protect your ego good good for him
big swinging dicks
i i love hello um
i mean that's the article it's in liar's
poker it's a term
that was a technical term sorry she
wasn't talking about you bro relax she
she
right they look like old old old
newspapers and it says
u.s steel relents and grants judicial
powers to government
and it's the days of teddy roosevelt the
trust busters and everything
and i think what you just saw everybody
thinks oh hahaha that's really kind of
funny you have to understand it the best
more money bessmar venture capital
boston
u.s steel carnegie and all this kind of
stuff haha
great joke for the intellectual but on
the other side of it
that's what just that's what played out
with diamond and powell that day that's
exactly what
it's like excuse me huge power play
we're not there's there's too big to
fail
and there's also too big with yep and so
and yep jamie diamond on that day was
too big
with god but remember speaking of
goldman sachs who was the
the only bank that was not in the room
the day that lehman failed
goldman sachs was down the hall at the
new york fed meeting individually with
timothy geithner while all the other
bankers in america
were at the other end of the new york
fed deciding what was going to happen
when lehman failed
lloyd blankfein was already moving way
past that he's like if
there's another company called aig it's
coming straight down the pipeline i
could give a damn about lehman
if you let aig go it's going to blow a
massive multi-billion dollar hole in my
balance sheet
so let lehman go rescue aig that's your
guy ben
uh ben moshe you know hollywood likes to
bend the facts a little bit but there is
a
i was actually at the federal reserve
that day there's a big
there is a there is a great scene that's
in
that's in you know the the biggest
question oh my gosh
it's at the end he goes hey they're at
the white house remember
yeah and he goes uh there's going to be
a bailout and
this is hollywood bending the facts and
everything but it actually there's some
truth to it there was some exact truth
to that
these guys were running over ford was
ford was bailed out
period yep and a year ago ford was
bailed out
period again and alan mulally sat there
in front of congress and claimed well
i'm the only one that didn't come here
on a corporate jet and he didn't
remember alan mulally who came to ford
from boeing and before that
rubbermaid i think um but if you're
listening to this you like this panel uh
smash that subscribe button and i think
a lot of alan malone
if you if you like today's panel
subscribe click that subscribe button
and the notifications
uh to be notified the next time one of
these podcasts comes out but go ahead
tom finish your thoughts
no i mean i think this is absolutely
correct it's like you have to look
directions when you turn on the lights
which way do all the cockroaches go
right and there was a bunch of
cockroaches went
this way and there was one that went
that way tom who is the most powerful
one today though like who calls the
shots is it still golden calling the
shots i don't know if it's calling shots
or it's
influence is goldman the most
influential still
they want to be i don't know what that
means though that means that jamin
jamie diamond was the pandemic changed
the dynamic
back it was a huge thing to see goldman
sachs fall below
jpmorgan chase in terms of influence
because jamie dimon had this
mammoth balance sheet that turned out to
be a weapon
that he could use so is goldman ahead
now
well goldman is to jamie dimon's point
about we lost deals
um he's not going anywhere how is jamie
dimon only worth 2 billion
what a loser no it's not about what a
loser with the amount of control and
influence he has
how much should he be worth i think he's
got to be a 22 sandy was a 20 to 40
billion dollar guy he would he would
have been absolutely
he would have been a magnificent
treasury secretary him diamond diamond
his name was in the running
making 200 grand a year no thank you
he'll go back to running good
no i disagree i think he's a patriot i
do too
i don't i don't disagree with that i
think he's a patriot then i think he
would serve his country
but i but i think he's in the right
place right now i think he's in the
right place right now
diamond is a patriotic moderate and his
left is basically on social issues
because he feels he doesn't want to be
on the wrong side of history
he is very predictable and i think i
think
very very highly of him you know people
of faith might say well i don't agree
with some of the social
you know side of him but i i i think
he's a moderate patriot
yeah every time i speak up for jamie
dimon my twitter feed just goes poof
what do they say they just all bankers
are evil wait i thought sandy was a twin
you get all the rothschild bilderberger
oh my gosh please don't
we can draw a line from sandy diamond
back to the rochester don't hit the
conspiracy theory button
no i'm not i'm just saying i'm i'm
envisioning where these tweets are oh my
gosh yes well
danielle is all about the the creatures
from jekyll island she's like all about
that she wrote a whole book about it and
you know so that we're not going to go
there no we're not let's go let's go to
the classic
uh moments in history how about before
we talk taxes
let's please adam let's talk about elon
musk okay
let's talk about elon musk because i
think uh elon
is inspiring adam i think adam is
gradually
also starting to have a thing for aliens
i don't know why but i think
you know gradually you're talking a lot
about aliens lately adam in space
yes i i can see that i can see that it's
interesting how you float in space i
think our audience is interested in this
story as well okay let's talk
how many times i want to know how many
times you're going to re-watch
saturday night live i think i know
you've already got it recorded right
i think elon musk hosting snl is going
to be a
ratings bonanza you know it's because of
him
going speculation because of him going
on snl
dogecoin is on fire up you know just
because they're thinking he's gonna
mention it
on snl but let me read this to you elon
musk arrives in new york city with
family brainstorms snl ideas
with paps with people out there this is
a tmz story illama still doesn't seem to
know
what the heck is in store for his big
debut on saturday night live and it's
even
escorted resorted to asking uh
photo uh what do you call it uh
paparazzi folks
about what skits he should do teslacio
was in new york city tuesday days ahead
of the taking the stage at nbc studios
where he'll be hosting snl and the
moment he showed his face in the streets
he was swarmed mostly by autograph
seekers who shoves dozens of sharpies
and
photos in his face the one thing on
everyone's mind is what he's got in
store for saturday's show
he regurgitated some ideas he was
spitballing on twitter over the weekend
including baby shark and shark tank
merging
to form baby shark tank doesn't seem
like he's touched base with
snl staff quite yet what do you think is
going to happen
so i don't i don't think we've ever seen
anyone like elon musk okay
so traditionally who were the we talked
about
uh the bezos of the world we talked
about gates we talked about buffett
last we've never seen a
multi-multi-billionaire with such a big
personality
and a weird personality all right this
guy's clearly banging aliens or has
fascinations about that all good
but someone with this much money this
much
power danielle we can go there you
should pull up a picture of his
girlfriend
kai just so danielle understands what
we're working with here stay on snl keep
going we'll stand outside now so
you had a bet with kai she's disabled a
couple a couple months ago
now pull up the more recent picture you
had a bet with kai a couple months ago
who would be a bigger draw on the joe
rogan podcast
you went with yes exactly danielle now
you're on my team
um kanye west or joe kanye west or elon
musk
was it even close i won that ten bucks
before the show even started kai you
still got that time
nine kai bet on kanye you bet on mars
who won
big-time not even close unfair this is
going to be the last kind like that on
tv again it hurts his ego well i don't
know from norway don't do that again
he's a big boy he could take it i
thought it was finland this guy's got a
what's the difference this is going to
be our ratings bonanza on snl i think
this is going to be way bigger than
of that norway school that listens to
podcasts keep going i think it's going
to be the biggest snl episode
ever potentially ever ever um because he
has a
a bigger than chappelle bigger than
murphy than trump yeah bigger than any
of these guys yes
john belushi back from dead i think it's
going to be i think it's going to be the
talk of the town on sunday who's john
belushi and i think it's going to be one
of those things
john belushi i think it's going to be a
car wreck situation where i don't think
he's actually that funny i think he's
like
he's got childish humor my hope is that
he can actually make fun of himself
like it it'll go very well if he can
embrace making fun of himself maybe he
can call it the white house i mean if
worse comes to worst they can just hook
him up to a teleprompter right
okay there it is yeah i if he like makes
something i could get out of trouble
somewhere
but oh my god
i think it's going to be a ratings
bonanza i think it's what do you guys
think what do you guys think
what do you think about it i think it's
going to be a letdown or you think it's
going to be like you know how you go to
a movie you're like oh my gosh i can't
wait to watch
transformers 3 and you're like yeah like
dude where the hell is shia labeouf and
uh the fox what's the the the other girl
from uh
megan fox megan fox what did i need shia
labeouf to be back in there and you're
kind of like a let down do you think
it's gonna be a letdown you think is
gonna come up and show up
yes i do on a one to ten i think it's
gonna be a two or a three and it's gonna
be like the remake of wall street where
oliver stone just
peed in the bed how about yourself
i mean i think i don't think it's going
to be entertaining as much
as it's going to be intriguing yeah
curiosity
yeah people are people just they're just
going to want to know you think it's
going to be like a car wreck like
everyone wants to see what's going on
but it's not gonna be
but it doesn't mean for people who
worship him and i mean he is probably
one of the most
worshipped people on the planet
everything he says is i mean hero
worship
he's talking up a joke yeah well that's
why i think dogecoin is
the bubble of all bubbles i think it's a
complete joke it's it started off as a
joke it still is a joke but just yeah
but people are
you're just upset that it's a dog not
cats so get off it
well played chat well played what do you
think about elon musk on snl what do you
think is going to happen
i think it's going to be very
interesting i think he is a
unpredictable guy and the world loves
unpredictable
characters an unpredictable character
can come up and say
anything he's going to push buttons the
question is going to be
who's he going to challenge when uh the
movie that what's the recent movie that
came out is it godzilla in uh uh
uh what is it he tweeted about he says i
love this movie there was a subtle shout
out to conspiracy theorists a shout out
to podcasters a shout out to this
he likes that so i think he's probably
going to do something with conspiracy
theorists i think he's probably going to
do
something with the number 420 69 doge
bitcoin i think he's gonna probably
touch something to do with jeff bezos i
think he's gonna take a shot at him
i think he's probably gonna take some
kind of a shot at possibly newsom
california i don't know i think i think
you don't know what direction he's gonna
go but
a lot of people right now are sitting
there saying they should have them do it
doesn't come up they should have him do
a skit as an amazon driver
that would be hilarious this is what
this is the kind of stuff he needs to do
make fun of himself make fun of others
this is a legacy type what
would you rather have on snl hey more
bezos who's not even a question not even
a question oh gosh
it's not even a question right i think
bezos although i'd like to see him and
bezos and amazon
delivery van do like carpool karaoke
that'd be great and i'd like to see noam
chan's gantana
that's what i'd like to see i'd like to
see that more than i'd like to see the
other one okay
all right if we cover that are you going
to tune in live
this what what is it saturday night
saturday night you're going to be miami
you may be tuning in in miami maybe okay
where am i
without the cats saturday i'm still i
live sunday yeah sunday
i'm going to tune in i'm going to go to
tune in to see tom
you tuning in nope bedtime what time is
bedtime
it's not bedtime i think it's kim's
birthday no it's mother's day
no that's that's that's that's the
following no no no we're doing we got
some
very big business things happening in
one of the other companies and so
saturday is mother's day yeah that's our
mother's day but you're not celebrating
mother's day
yes dylan got a suit yesterday i got
dylan we're doing it mother's day
there's a law against that
well the price for the gift doubles so
if you can meet that requirement move it
yeah you can look at danielle you can
buy danielle with uh
if i was told you're you're not gonna
get one but two pairs of
shoes with red soles i'd be like so yes
we'll change it one day is all we're
asking for so anyway so that's that part
let's get to the story of taxes i want
to do this tax story on page nine go to
page nine
taxes taxes mansion mansion management
we're trying to talk about snl you wanna
talk about taxes
wealthy may face up to 61 percent tax
rate on
inherited wealth under biden plan that's
a cnbc story
uh sixty-one percent of heroism joe
biden tax plan according to a recent
analysis
as part of his uh american family's plan
biden is proposing to nearly double the
top tax rate on capital gains and
eliminate tax benefits on this
appreciated assets known as the step up
in-base step up in bases
combining the estate tax and the new
higher capital gains rate the repeal of
step up and basis could bring total
effective marginal
tax rates as high as 61
are you kidding me according to an
analysis from the tax foundation the
rate would be the highest such
rate in nearly a century i'll give this
to you and then i'm going to give you a
janet yellen update right afterwards go
ahead tell us about this
well it's asinine there's not really
much to talk about
it's not i mean i'm assuming you're
supportive you're really looking forward
to the tax hike to 61
look we are all the great social things
we can do together
all the great programs but i'm all over
philanthropy but you're going to
decimate philanthropy if you do this
that's correct i mean if you think about
the ford
ford's come up three times the ford
foundation and what it's done
in this country and so many other
family legacies that have done things
that the government
wouldn't and shouldn't do shouldn't i
mean there's always a place for
philanthropy but not with that tax rate
it's not and by the way
did i say china i mean they've got to
love things like this
they have to i mean there will be people
who leave
there will be people who get up and
leave the country where are they going
belize costa rica there's a bunch of
places out there that you can live
very nicely i mean you do have to kind
of live off the grid
singapore is at the top you put
singapore there
i mean i mean singapore is definitely a
place for the wealthy to live it's not
hong kong
you think people are actually going to
leave i think that you would have a
handful of people who left i mean think
about
okay september the 9th 1850 california
was admitted into the united states
okay every single year
since 1850 the population of california
has grown
dot dot dot until preliminary census
data suggests
2020. there was a 70 000 some odd
net loss of population in the state of
california
you can't tell me that people don't try
and flee
high tax high tax
cities states but what if it's the
country 1850 till 2020 it's grown
it's crazy stopped 170 years later 2020.
shout out to gavin newsom oh god
give me back that electoral vote okay
let's take a vote one of you
57 now 56 or something like that it's um
kai how many were did they that's
exactly right if you look at if you look
at california losing a seat that's
exactly right
that's exactly and he's major williams
he needs to use that stat right there
major williams he's
used that stat right there yeah shout
out to major okay
speaking of your man crush where does
elon musk hang his hat
austin texas that's true in boca chica
boca raton boca chica there it is but
think about i don't think anyone's
moving to
when you said a handful are you
literally saying a handful like how many
people are leaving the country because
of this
genuine question who's going to
singapore some people are going to
puerto rico these days but that's still
part of this country models you can move
some business models you cannot eduardo
true the truth true some people are
moving to puerto rico like
hey pat come to puerto rico be part of
the 420 program pay only four percent
taxes for 20 years
our model doesn't work i wouldn't be
able to go over there anyways but i know
a lot of hedge fund managers who've gone
there
sure i i know and that's all they need
is a computer that's that's the
difference certain jobs you can i pay
taxes in every state i'm appointed in
i'm still paying taxes in california
every every quarter they come a pad
here's to cut the taxes check check
check check check i'm talking
i'm not saying it's the right thing to
do and by the way
it's i mean talk about the midterms i
mean
if they if they try and raise taxes to
this extent
the midterms will be even so you don't
think it's going to go to 61.
you don't think this is going to pass i
i can't see it hap i can't see mansion
letting it happen so so are you familiar
with the reagan tax act
uh what was it in 1986 do you know the
numbers on what he did yeah david
stockman trickle-down economics
did you know actually the numbers what
he did no the numbers would have
but i know he i know the capital gains
change
released release dollars that ran
into both philanthropy and venture
capital as a historical fact
so he brought ordinary income kai helped
me out he brought ordinary income from
50 to 28
he raised lowest marginal tax rate from
11 to 15 okay and he brought
uh uh capital gains to 28.
everything was 28 28 and the lowest one
from 11 to 15
is what reagan did and it passed right
and obviously a couple years they did
have some changes to it but he brought
from 50 to 28.
to go to 61 here
i mean this is catastrophic if this
passes
if it passes say it does pass if it
you're talking about people leaving to
another country you know when i hear
this story about people leaving to
another country it reminds me when
democrats said if trump gets elected i'm
moving to canada
okay look i'm not saying it's the right
thing to do and i'm not
saying that big names will do it what
the heck's going to say
some podcasters some engineers some
coders
i'm saying people people who have enough
wealth to care
but they can do their job as you say
anywhere
i'm out of here yeah sixty percent
that's nuts to be thinking about that
direction they're going let me read the
janet yellen story right afterwards
because i know you're a big fan of hers
brought to you by maybelline and
covergirl treasury's yelling biting
programs
to make big difference to inequality
reuters story u.s president joe biden's
overall proposal which includes
stepped up spending on infrastructure
child care and education will make a big
difference in
inequality u.s treasury sector secretary
janet yellen
said in remarks released on tuesday
republicans have criticized the proposed
tax increase
biden expects to use to pay for his
proposals but yellen said the effect of
a change in marginal tax rates
is much less powerful in influencing
growth in either direction adding that
her aim is to make sure
government deficits stay small and
manageable yellen also suggested
u.s interest rates may need to rise to
prevent the economy from overheating
as more of president biden's economic
investment programs
come online so do you think
the rates are about to increase
dramatically and if yes
how dramatic okay so she got her hand
slapped
that day the nasdaq dropped 400 the dow
was off by 350 points
uh somebody do you think she cares uh
she she renounced her statement that day
what i meant to say was she is the
treasury secretary she is a political
appointee she is no longer
the chair of the federal reserve
interest rates are not her purview
that is the the singular purview of jp
that's like j pal coming out and saying
the federal reserve advocates for a
strong dollar policy
the fed's not allowed to talk about the
dollar that is the sole purview of the
treasury secretary she crossed
a big line it was highly highly
inappropriate what she did
and she had to come back and walk it
back because
j pal had spent the prior week telling
all of america that he wasn't even
thinking about thinking about reducing
quantitative easing reducing
the pace at which money is being printed
he was on an evangelism tour
he was for a whole week and she comes
out
and just slaps that and by the way
you've got to stop
growing the fed's balance sheet before
you can even get to raising interest
rates
she skipped right over that process and
said that she saw interest rates is
rising
and the market threw up yep but it
wasn't her place
so what are you saying you're saying the
rates are not going to go up anytime
soon no she was speaking with the brain
of her priorities i totally get that i
got the point what i'm saying is do you
think
rates are not at all going to go federal
reserve is not going to increase
interest rates
anytime soon is he going to keep his
commitment of 2023 because that's what
he said in the past before we'll see
the pressure is building on jay powell
like you've
never read because as mentioned input
cost prices whether you're talking about
copper
or l or lumber is whatever it is crazy
30-16
insane but shipping freight uh costs
are are higher than they've ever been we
don't have truck drivers in the country
and now labor's more expensive because
biden's policy is paying people to not
work correct so you
and and labor 60 of any given company's
cost structure correct
is labor if jay powell is going to be
facing
companies that are they're challenged
with extraordinary inflation
and for him to hold the line through
and watch this thing blow up
and it's it's hard to see him holding
the line
unless unless these unemployment
benefits expire which
that this is what he's banking on he's
banking on september the 6th
he's banking on companies being able to
hold on long enough
to wait until unemployment benefits
expire and people are forced back into
the workforce
exactly i completely agree with that and
there's also something that we missed
that came out of the charlie and warren
show
charlie stole the headlines with all of
his
crypto and bitcoin oh i hate it it's
terrible it you know supports you know
kitchen
yeah the kidnappers domestic terrorists
and people that can go
you know and use the you know the the
dark side of the web and
i'm texting something to kai to share so
i'm on my phone
now then here's what they forgot and i
don't think you missed it
um and we haven't spoken about this in
advance but i know this is not something
you would have missed
charlie and warren spoke for 10 minutes
that they are
already seeing inflation that could be
as high as six to seven percent this
year in america
and he said we are seeing costs pass
between our companies
where companies doing business with each
other he mentioned sugar and coke
he and now you've already brought up
transportation costs shortage of truck
drivers
and uh lumber and where we have actually
you brought up correctly
we have iron ore is it a record today
there you go so they're already saying
you know uh is nobody paying attention
here we're we're seeing a six to seven
percent inflation
this year and it and it could be it
could be even greater and we're
seeing it all right now all these houses
and everything in
south florida going up that's also
driving up rent that's also driving up
property taxes
because it's all ad valorem the property
tax is a trailing indicator that follows
the increase in housing prices
so if you have an increase in housing
prices and a lot of transactions
all those transaction houses now are
retaxed or
to me they're rebased and they're taxed
tomorrow and we're wondering why biden's
already talking about a fourth stimulus
check
because without extra money all of a
sudden households are going to get
slammed what did you think about all
this in their talk on inflation i sat
back and i'm like why are they giving
charlie a headline on
crypto and bitcoin what they just said
about inflation
yeah it was and and and you're right
charlie munger has no i've warren
buffett invited me out to omaha years
ago so
i i enjoyed charlie munger's company
much more one of those little cpo
unhinged i mean he says yeah there you
go it was a sapio moment
in my world i can see that because on
the opposite side there's nothing else
going on there but
warren buffett got warren just keep
saying ebitda
he got a ton of criticism because he
didn't talk about anything controversial
in his annual letter
people are like this week saturday uh
no no his annual letter which came out
prior to it right right
so i think he wanted to exert his
influence
and he took that's what we talked about
and he used the microphone to do it
he did it for a reason it was a vanilla
letter because the other shoe
was live yeah i mean and he is but but
when you
when you say interest rates are going to
rise
you're taking a political shot at janet
yellen saying
ma two trillion more four trillion more
won't make a difference we had the tools
to fight inflation
she says it over and over and over again
we have the tools to fight inflation
not if it runs off the rails and slams
the economy into
into a recession because companies
cannot afford how do you stop the
inflation right now
what what what monger and buffett were
talking about
this is not government-driven inflation
this is
market-driven inflation how are you
going to stop it how are you going to
suddenly
invent more lumber to increase the
supply of lumber tomorrow morning bring
the cost up but by 2022 we will have the
sawmills
we will have extra capacity but next
year a long time about right now it's a
long time from now
you can't you can't stop what's about to
happen economically ahead of the
midterms
it's going to be a slaughter part of the
midterm 16 months
yeah hero
confidence is pretty high though by the
way if rates go up but you think rates
are going to go up in the next five
years to the six seven eight percent
numbers or no
well the problem is that what what
they're flirting with and what they're
flirting with
is is and and milton friedman when we
tell you this
we've had a 40-year run of falling
inflation falling interesting
40 years normally postcards 18 said
whatever cds were paying
16 and a half percent milton friedman
would tell you that if you let the
inflation genie out of the bottle
it's really hard to get her back in and
that's when things run off the roads
especially when we're spending money
like we're drunken sailors the
government
we are drunken sailors yeah
maybe they want that maybe they actually
want that if you think about it
i think that biden thinks he might be
the next fdr which makes him delusional
because his infrastructure plan has to
be put in hyper quotes because it's
the actual infrastructure spending being
proposed is less than what obama
proposed coming out of the financial
crisis and obama already
crazy it's insane it's in i mean there's
trillions and trillions of dollars of
infrastructure spending that could put
americans to work
i mean according to mr chomsky they
don't want that job nor should they have
to take it
um so now hang on a minute these are
shovel-ready projects that i got out
there obama himself came out and said it
didn't work
obama himself when i say that can we go
to a couple other stories i want to do
one story i want to do the aol yahoo
story because there's some some
interesting uh stories behind that with
yahoo
huh just a small launch yeah what a
story though if you think about it okay
so
verizon just sold aol and yahoo for five
billion dollars and a new company will
be known as
yahoo going forward a business insider
story after just over five years of
ownership ryzen has sold this uh
ownership stake in yahoo
nao for five billion the telecom giant
announced on monday morning the new
company formed by aol and yahoo will be
known
the new company owner is private equity
firm apollo
global management marquee media groups
being purchased in the deal include
uh inga jet tech crunch yahoo finance
other notable products and the sale also
include all dial up internet customer
base yahoo mail and yahoo portal
homepage
verizon originally purchased ao back in
may of 2015 for 4.4 billion dollars in
yahoo in july
for 4.83 billion dollars making the sale
of both companies for 5 billion about a
50 percent
overall loss thoughts quite a haircut
yes it is a huge haircut and apollo
still might be overpaying
i mean did you see part of the deal is
the aol dial up yes
oh my gosh so guys we got this dial up
hang on isn't it like 1.5 million people
that are still paying like 24
a month yeah it i mean there is aol
dialogue because they forgot to cancel
uh or something my understanding is it's
24 to 26 million dollars a month that's
sitting there folks if you're a quarter
billion dollars
for that you may want to go take a look
at your credit card bill you may still
be paying 24.95
from 20 years ago well it just shows how
the world has changed
so quickly you're talking about aol and
yahoo were they not the two biggest
internet providers yes yeah in the year
2000 i mean i still got my aol account
that i'll give to somebody if i don't
want that they were disrupted
crazy aol is a network provider and
yahoo had partnered with the um the rbox
like sbc
and they were providing so spc was
providing you know the dsl early dsl to
your
home what happened here this is
the fallacy of expanded product
what happened is verizon went out and
bought a bunch of media assets that they
thought were going to pump through
phones and do things like that
i remember verizon tried to build a
thing called vcast as its own
network a tv network that would be on
your phone with all this interesting
content and everything and they were
going to be
you know they were going to be the cable
system on your phone and what they
failed to understand is they were a
platform
uh the mobile platform was a platform
and you had media out there already you
just had to figure out how to get the
media on it make a buck on it
apple figured out 30 please for the
we're the platform with the phone we're
going to make stuff no everybody else
will make stuff but we'll take 30
of everything that comes through the
tollbooth that's what verizon should
have done that's what sprint should have
done
they were fools and so they went out and
bought all this remember huffington post
was part of this
yes it was they were they were spun out
of this yep and they got a guy named tim
armstrong who came here and they
rebranded the whole thing
oath i think it was oath as i recall
and they're going to do this it's going
to be different and tim armstrong also
said oh by the way we're going to do
something else with um
with aol we're going to have citizen
journalism he had a name for it remember
it was always going to be citizen
journalism that
gives you local stories are very
interesting and everything i said i
already have that it's called twitter i
just
hashtag dallas and i have all kinds of
citizen journalists up there
um and so this is just the fallacy of
this i
what's really funny about this is when
gopro hired people i believe it was from
hbo
and they said hey we're going to make
the we're going to make the gopro media
network and we're going to do our own
media and everything
why do you have to do that you sold
millions and millions of these cameras
all your
customers are making all the media you
curate it and offer it you're not the
media company
but there is a fantasy about being the
content creator content provider
that gopro and verizon had and it was
this is just a remarkably bad idea
and i happen to agree when i look at
this and i put it through
my thought in terms of private equity i
don't think i don't think yahoo
i don't think these two companies worth
two billion dollars and i think
set your clock apollo is going to dish
this off to somebody and it's going to
mark down again
because it's a 5 billion write-off for
um verizon
so if you want to buy verizon you've got
uh potential some losses
yeah discount i just i just took a deep
dive into private equity um
for my weekly and private equity sitting
on 1.6
trillion dollars of dry powder and they
can't find targets which is the same
problems
they have nothing to buy and i mean if
you look at the post pandemic there was
like five minutes
where they could buy distressed
companies and then jay pal came into the
bailout
so their window for buying distressed
closed quickly so now they're paying
i'm going to be missed my warren buffett
moment they're paying 11.4 times ebitda
we've never seen multiples like this in
private equity
but they can't they have to get rid of
the money they have i mean and and
public pensions
we talked about that throwing the money
yeah by the way do you know what was the
maximum
problem too do you know what's the
highest aol was valued at one point
market cap highest ever you know what ao
was hiding some guesses i like guesses
what do we got what do you think if
you're listening to this give me aol and
give me yahoo what was yahoo worth the
most at one point what was aol worth the
most at one point
highest ever market cap circa 2000
what's the number what do you think i i
don't recall but just throw a number out
there
probably the morning that 250 billion
combined
250 billion over combined no i was going
to aol is 250 billion and yahoo's what
same i mean microsoft just crossed two
trillion right so
what are you gonna say a while ago by
the way this is five billion dollars
they bought both of them for so just
keep this part in mind
maybe a hundred billion
follow the aol markdown game starting
with um aol time order bought my time
award i think it's
the number just give a number i i don't
know okay
yes this is now this is not a test buddy
it's not like no one's failing you're a
or
four billion four billion yeah four
billion way off
aol was a 200 billion auto company ding
ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding
ding ding was a 200 company and yahoo
was 100 billion dollar company
max do you know 100 billion combined the
moment where you saw
yahoo kind of go in a bad direction you
kind of went in that direction is when
they bought broadcast if you remember
when they bought broadcast from our cube
and they bought broadcast from mark
cuban on april 1st 99 you know for how
much
5.6 billion dollars they bought
broadcast for 5.6 billion
which was a mark cuban company more
than aol and aol and yahoo today which
when that company sold in that time
three years later they shut the company
down i think 30
of their shares uh cuban owned one 70
was uh
wagner's shares and from that point on
yeah i was like wait a minute what just
happened here we just bought a company
we wrote it off three years later
the check went over there because one
year you know the company grew 250
percent when they went public so market
wanted it they got it and also at
the same time if you read ted turner's
book
and you follow his uh history
when did his demise come when did this
fall come
is when he went and did business with
the
time warner aol that whole merger that
took place
looking back he lost control when he was
leading everything was good the moment
he had no longer had voice he no longer
had any influence so
there are certain dealings you know you
do certain acquisitions certain things
work out good certain things don't
and we're running a record record run
right
last two months speaking of expensive
celebrity divorces
which one is ted turner yeah well yeah
that's another one
well the um two two points here warren
buffett said in his latest annual
meeting
do you know what percentage of companies
that were the top 20 companies
in the world are still in in 1995 are
still in the top 20. oh this is the s p
migration over time yeah do you know how
many zero
zero so like all these companies that
were just gangsters back in 2000
are nothing now and then that's why we
have we
we need to home grow our scientists and
mathematicians
because we need to come up with whatever
the next generation is going to be
if adam has it his way it's not going to
happen it's happening we're going to
space me and my cats are going to space
what's funny is i remember being like
this was probably in early 2000s i was
a senior in college and i remember
asking friends
um all right who do you use as your
search engine because i was still using
yahoo
and there was like 10 people in the room
and everyone used google and i was like
what do you mean yahoo guys
they're like nah i don't think about
that yet and one engineer said lycos
yeah
and so they were all moving to google
and i was still on yahoo so that means
that at some point you're going to
understand the space race
thing one of these days you just got to
play catch up 100
of people were interested in 1960. hang
on twenty percent of people you think
how do you know 100 we're interested in
high school then i remember
i'm an old soul did you hear she just
did by the way your lip is bleeding she
hit you pretty good there
okay i can take it someday you'll
understand the space adam actually can't
take it
see adam there's a spectrum right so a
one
is two shots in a panther right two
shots of tequila and a panther
and a ten is the space race you're just
living at three we just need you to come
on down
i know i offended your dad this is the
rocket scientist it's okay we'll figure
things out watch what's going to happen
afterwards guys guys
hell so you're talking [ __ ] about my dad
what you're going to see a rocket
scientist fight by the way it's legit
you know how they do it
they actually don't fight they just blow
up your office what they do tom tom had
a reputation
they're going to pull out their pocket
protector you know adam's office
the set is gone
protector can you imagine how many
people are listening right now who are
google
projector what the hell
were you ever into guys that were pocket
protectors hell no why not
i thought you were uh uh sapien uh
brain sapien what's that word with i
thought you were a homosexual section
and less than two hours later you don't
even remember topics did you guys see
what happened in colombia or no do you
guys watch any of the video and what's
going on
so let's read that i had some friends
from colombia said do you mind covering
the story so
i say let's just go and talk about it
what page is it on page 11
colombia um this is the police
heavy-handed
riot police bring wave of criticism on
columbia this is a bloomberg story
columbia is facing a wave of
wave of criticism from foreign
governments and human rights
organization
over heavy-handed police tactics during
recent protests demonstrations
erupted last week in protest against a
plan by the government of a president
yvonne duke to raise taxes more marches
are planned by labor union wednesdays
even though the tax proposal
was withdrawn and the finance minister
resigned the u.n office for human rights
state
said in a statement that it was deeply
alarmed by police opening fire on
demonstrators and
colleague third largest city on monday
night
and this led to 20 people who have died
so far in the recent days and clashes
between protesters and
security forces the police said that
nearly 600 officers have been injured
and that they have been repeatedly
attacked with firearms
defense minister diego molano said that
colombia is facing a terrorist threat
from organized crime gangs who are
seeking to destabilize
cities including bokota medellin and
kali what do you think about what's
going on there
philosophical looks like they want to
make it the next venezuelan the people
are saying we are not
up for that we saw how that works out
we're not willing to go there do you
think
who wins in this battle who wins in this
battle the people
or the socialists the people
okay i mean look we have a venezuelan
and a colombian sitting right there
uh in our control room in our country
who wins sambal
who wins here you you have family in
colombia
you think the people win have you spoken
to your family in colombia
yes what are they telling you what's
happening over there how bad is it so
basically it's over the reform of taxes
also is because
basically the reform is saying we're
going to raise taxes but then
still the country is totally shut down
because of the pandemic
so they're like we're barely getting any
food
any money to buy food and now you're
getting us
getting that money out of us like how
are we gonna make
how are we going to survive and what do
you say being from venezuela and your
family
having left what do you say to folks of
colombia keep fighting because i told
this adam before the podcast i honestly
believe me being venezuelan that
venezuela is
screwed already oh i i lived in i lived
in caracas
before chavez came in and he's made a
train wreck of that country
and people have to remember that
colombia is has been colombia borders
venezuela so colombia has
a ton of venezuelan refugees so they
know what the other side looks like
because they're with them and they're i
don't i don't think the colombians are
going to stand down on this no no i have
friends in colombia too
and i keep i keep telling them i keep
fighting because i do believe they have
the chance but they cannot stop just
keep pushing that's it
right they have the cl the case example
of what not to do literally right next
door yeah i mean so
i mean social media wasn't a thing when
venezuela was basically taking over but
now the world's
watching when we were speaking to juan
guido's camp am i saying the name
correctly when why those camp he was
going up against maduro we offered to
want to interview maduro we'd come to
colombia i wanted to sit down with them
they said no but guido the camp was open
to it
only if we conduct the interview in
colombia
so the interview was in colombia so even
not venezuela they felt safer in
colombia but imagine
if colombia goes in the direction of
venezuela imagine what's going to happen
there
well here's what they need um and in a
macro sense so they have two problems
here
it's like greece where they have these
failed government policies that just
is a disaster and now they have to press
the tax button which was the austerity
plan which is the opposite of tax you
get nothing so you're getting tax you're
getting less as a retiree in greece and
that everything blew up over there
seven years ago so first of all they've
got this tinder box that's been created
by
bad government policy for the people the
second thing they have
is they've got a corruption element and
what they really need is similar to what
happened in the philippines
25 years ago when benito aquino came
back unfortunately he was assassinated
as he was stepping off the plane
but corazon aquino and laban helped
stabilize what was going on in the
philippines remember this it was messy
it was tough it was 10 years getting
things on its feet
but there is a voice that is needed and
somebody needs to rise up i think in the
days of social media
it gives candidates and people
opportunity to do that because i think
columbia can survive
but i agree that people can't stop they
got to keep they can't
not burning things down but they got to
keep the presence of the people to put
the pressure on it
because they need a new they need a new
leadership in the government
because it's a combination of greece and
corruption all together and
but they've seen it played out and it
doesn't have to end badly but it's going
to be a long walk together but look how
they're spinning it though defense
minister diego molano said that colombia
is facing a
terrorist threat from organized crime
gangs
who are seeking to destabilize cities
including bogota medina
as sam said before some of that sure as
sam said before we came on they're
taking a
page out of the united states playbook
that's what they're doing of course they
are yeah they saw what worked
let us do the same thing it's propaganda
yeah and you know i mean
there's something to be said for i mean
there's some bad stuff going on down
there look peru's about to elect a
very leftist president on the cusp
in brazil the the the current bolsonaro
was part of the military regime that
existed in brazil
he just had the the head of of of
brazil's largest oil company
stepped down and he replaced him with a
military guy
so there's some bad stuff going on down
in south america it's not
not good if you're the united states you
look at this from a macro perspective
central america is already a [ __ ] show
right with everything
the migration everything that's
happening coming through mexico showing
up at our borders the last thing we need
is south america to turn even more
reckless especially when they do most of
their business with
china
[Music]
well the good news is i think uh the the
president here ivan duque
he already asked the tax proposal and
apparently the finance
minister resigned does he have a choice
we'll see
we're with the people let me go into the
story with india
so coronavirus how india descended into
kobe 19 chaos this is a bbc story
in january february the national number
of daily cases fell under 20 000
from peaks of 90 000 in september of
last year prime minister
modi declared covet beaten and all
places are public gathering open and
soon people were not adhering to the
kova safety protocols
thanks thanks in part to confuse
messaging from the top
while modi asked people to wear masks
and follow social dissonance public
messages
he addressed large unmasked crowds
during his election campaigns and five
states a number of his ministers
were also seen addressing large public
gatherings without wearing a mask the
kuma
the the kumbala a hindu festival which
attracts millions was also allowed to go
ahead
anyways this goes into the number of
india initially wanted 300 million
people
vaccinated by july but it seems the
government did not do enough planning to
secure vaccine supply to run the program
on top of it it has opened the
vaccination for adults without securing
vaccine supply so here's a number we're
looking at
so far only 26 million people in india
have been fully vaccinated out of a
population of 1.4 billion
and about 124 million have received a
single dose india has millions more
doses on
doses on order but still far short of
what it actually needs this is what they
need the federal government needs 615
million doses
of vaccinate to vaccinate everyone above
the age of 45 by 440 million people
there are 622 million people ages 18 to
and 1.2 million doses doses are required
to vaccinate them
catastrophic situation going on there
here's what china did they have pop-up
crematoriums
that's a by the way you were talking
about 400 000 people
a day a day a day right now yeah by the
way the united states has fallen
down on this maintaining india
as a key ally means that we should have
been
sharing hey this is how you distribute
vaccines
proactive with them i mean we have i
mean we've done it
we've distributed we've done it and
we've done it successfully it was
planned
beautifully we have people in our
military who can be advising
the leadership in india and and what
have we done it's like there's mr magoo
in the white house i didn't say that
chinese government authorities deleted
post mock in india i'm going to read
this and i'm going to turn it over to
adam chinese government authorities the
leader post mocking india's covenanting
tragedy after receiving backlash this is
another business
insider story images on social media by
the way can you try to find this image
of the pictures posted on the article
images on social media posted by two
chinese official
accounts are drawn rebuked for appearing
to mock
india's catastrophic battle with covet
19 an account link to the ruling
communist party posted
an image on saturday comparing this
country's successful launch of his
taiyan module
into space with lines of burning
cremation priors in india the image
posted by government central
political legal affairs commissions on
weibo account was captioned
china lighting of fire versus india
lighting a fire it carried a hashtag
noting india's coronaviruses
cases top 400 000 a day multiple other
government accounts run by the police
and law enforcement agency shared an
image too
posts were deleted after many chinese
weibo users expressed anger at the
insensitivity
expressed what are you thinking
well i think china learned a few things
from dealing with donald trump
uh you know how to do a trade war uh and
how to be a troll
so this uh the the this response right
here is very
trumpy of china to basically troll
a very sad situation that's going on in
india and then the only reference that i
have for india
is that they were actually doing a great
job beating the coronavirus and then
they pulled it to sean jackson
and basically spiked the ball to one
yard line
and the game has completely changed and
now they're
the poster child for basically taking
your eye off the ball when it comes to
covet
tom this goes back to what danielle said
earlier about an hour ago we were
talking about and
worse the dependency on uh vaccine
manufacturing right now
and who would be happy to sit on this
side of the line and let
india twist for a little while yep china
absolutely
this is this is this is this was not a
dig
china's love industry this was a dig to
the united states that post was screw
you
and i'm not gonna help yeah that's
exactly why don't you turn to your
friends
in the white house and see what they're
gonna do for you
well what happened if india says china
we need your help that's the only person
that can give them 1.2 million dollars
exactly right did they go begging saying
hey please help us
i mean the magnitude of this tragedy is
hard to i mean
how does china react does china say no
how do you wrap your head around 400 000
people a day
how does china respond to it though if
they come out and publicly ask
yeah oh i think that puts china in a
really tough spot
but but but you're talking about modi
here
do you see that happening i don't think
i don't see that happening why would
they be in a tough spot if they did it
publicly
well because it would if china didn't do
it they would seem as a very
you know tarantula what do they care
the europeans are getting on the on the
human rights train
that they've china's under a microscope
and you think they care the ccp cares
about
they have to act like they do to get
into other smaller countries
to have control they have to seem
magnanimous they do
they're already in africa they have
major infrastructure investments that
are made because they do
bothering these countries into the debt
trap this morning did you see cnn's uh
instagram account this morning
can you pull up that article this
morning six reasons why young adults
need to get vaccinated i think that's
what it says six reasons why young
healthy people need to get vaccinated go
to the next one
long-term consequence of covid can be
quite serious for young adults can you
flip the screen to go on that instead of
ours
go ahead tom you see the guy josh
skidmore
the first comment six reasons why cnn
came back
i'm looking at the woman who gave birth
to nine babies two more than expected on
the bottom yeah i saw that as well so
long-term consequences of covet can be
cop you got to hear point number six by
the way
long-term consequence of kovat can be
quite serious for young adults i cannot
tell
you how many people have taken care of
in the er who in their 20s 30s and 40s
who are never
sick enough to end up in the er with
covet but who now have long-lasting
respiratory difficulties okay
fine so long-term keep going to the next
one uh strong and healthy immune systems
can backfire some young healthy patients
have suffered from covet
uh storms that's basically when an
immune system overreacts which can cause
severe inflammation other serious
symptoms
when young people do succumb to cover 19
pronounce that word for me cytokine
storms are often a factor said dr paul
offit that
uh was really the story of the 1918
pandemic the flu pandemic we have
u-shaped curve it was a young and
old dying for different reasons okay go
to the next one this is next
third reason if young people don't give
vaccinated it could leave
everyone vulnerable we get that go to
the next one getting vaccinated will
help the economy many restaurants bars
movie theaters and supporting menus
aren't open at full capacity either
because the covenant case numbers are
still too high or because not enough
people have been
vaccinated go to the next one so they're
there so the reason why restaurants are
not opening up is because of the people
not because the us government that's
what they're saying vaccines can save
people lots of money
copenhagen could get very expensive
medical bills lost work days and
potential for more doctors visits if you
get a long-term effect from covered okay
keep going to the next one
getting vaccinated can up your dating
game this is the one okay
for those on dating scene getting
vaccinated or being open to getting it
is the hottest thing you could do said
michael kai spokesperson for dating site
okay cupid he said users who answered
yes
to will you get the kovit 19 vaccine
have been liked up to
25 more than those who answered no
or chose not to answer in just three
months tinder had a 258
increase in profile mentions of the word
vaccine
spokesperson dana bulge said so i don't
know i don't know i saw
big media coverage of crowds in daytona
beach crowds in miami crowds in south
padre island it doesn't look like the
youth were waiting for uh vaccines
last summer to scratch the depends on
where you are i i've taken two trips to
new york in the last few
months and people are really they're
like yeah i got over the hump today
i've you know and they're like brand new
excited they're like wow i'm out i'm out
i'm out i'm having a blast
i know some millennials who are like the
same way i
my co the co-founder of my company we're
sitting at lunch and he's like this is
my first lunch out danielle and i'm like
excuse me he's like yeah i waited two
weeks after i got my second vaccine and
i'm like
congratulations but there are some
people who take it pretty seriously it
is true
so so here's the crazy thing what
happened with bora bora we're supposed
to be bora bora in four weeks
we get a letter from bora bora oh here's
what did you hear about bora bora
letter from bora bora saying there's
only two way you can come we're taking
like 150 people
there's only two way you can come you
can come only
if 100 of people are vaccinated or if
whoever comes is willing to
quarantine two weeks after being here to
go back to the states even walking off
the plane with a negative test
two weeks quarter so maldives is open
turks and caicos is open but if you want
to go to bora bora today
you need to take a vaccine shot for them
to let you in
you need to show the guy you're not
going to bore a borah not our group
so we are looking at a couple other
options right now where they're going
we're supposed to be there four or five
weeks so now we're gonna
take a couple of other options i've
taken my hat off to the bahamians
yeah bora bora managed they're doing a
really really good job they're doing a
really good job i mean
and you saw what happened with australia
prime minister saying anybody that wants
to come here from india if you travel to
you cannot come back where else it's a
fifty thousand dollar fine and what is
it how long
in jail fifty one fifty one thousand
dollar fine and you'll be in jail for
a month two months maximum penalties
five years in jail and a fifty thousand
dollar fine if you come back if you're
an
australian citizen you fly back from
india to australia it's a fifty one
thousand dollar fine and five years in
jail
that's what the australian prime
minister said scott morrison
okay so if you ever go to india make
sure you don't go to australia because
they're going to put you in jail for
five years that's not a good idea
gang we've had a good time with you if
you enjoyed today's uh yes we have a
video from thompson oh do we is it ready
hey tom how you doing tom let's hear
what tom's got to say
zen are in the house put it up there but
there's a video here he said
uh let's see by the way it's a risk when
we play we don't know what tom's gonna
say
no one knows what tom's gonna say okay
could be controversial
could be controversial or it could just
be in general what is on your
cardinal book are cats involved
so obviously he wanted me to preface
this uh he left last night he's been
following the podcast
and he has some very helpful advice all
right let's hear what he's got to say
hey what's up everybody patrick danielle
tom adam you got a full house and a
great show
i'm watching thumbs up all the way from
me and here's the deal today on
vtpost.com i'm going to continue some of
the themes that you guys are hammering
so far
number one elon musk how stupid is that
cast of saturday night live
for putting up you know some roadblocks
to him being on the show it's gonna be
highly rated but
for one reason alone they should want
elon musk on the show the after party
i guarantee you he will spend at least
700 million dollars before tips on the
after party
by the way pete davidson is the one guy
that's for elon musk and we'll have a
story on that now
i'm obsessed with the bill and melinda
gates divorce i just can't get enough of
it
today we're going to do a story on the
house in seattle
the sickest house in the in there who's
going to get possession of that house
we've got that story today
and here's my theory i don't think bill
gates is a sapiosexual anymore
no i think he's going a completely
different route in round two and we're
gonna see that play out with who he's
dating in the future
and finally adam this is for you now i
want you to think about this
pull a bill gate go back to the
ex-girlfriend
redo the breakup settlement give her the
cats
trust me to get married you have to give
all the
attention to your woman shout out to my
videographer here this morning now adam
i'm going to leave you with this
shonda if you continue to have cats this
i believe is going to be the options for
you for marriage
i don't think there's a chance in hell i
don't think there's
a chance any help i don't
play tom center adam you're the full
package you can be married by the end of
the weekend in south beach if you get
rid of the cats
tom you are hilarious everybody hey
go to vtpost.com and give the man a
shout out and subscribe for a dollar a
month for three months and then it's
3.99 per month after that with that
being said
take care everybody daniel thank you for
coming out tom thank you for coming out
great to be here good to be here
thank you so much next week thursday
we're off on tuesday because we're in
dallas
but we'll be here next week thursday
take care everybody bye bye bye
you